Netflix is dropping more than a few
exciting new releases this November the
final season of house of cards is making
its debut this month along with the
Chris Pine led the outlaw King and
that's just the tip of the iceberg
he has everything good coming to Netflix
in November 2018
even though Kevin Spacey's out the
picture his character Frank Underwood
will apparently still play into the
events of the final season of house of
cards according to Reuters the exact
cause of his death will be something of
a lingering mystery that's sticking
around to haunt his widow and the new
president Claire and the word check it
out when house of cards returns on
November 2nd journey back to the
clashing cultures of 1970 with
remastered tricky dick and the man in
black a documentary about that time
Johnny Cash went to the White House to
hang out with Richard Nixon this is the
second installment in Netflix's musical
documentary series the first of which
remastered who shot the sheriff delved
into the 1976 assassination attempt on
Bob Marley look for tricky dick and the
man in black on November 2nd only in
2018 with the epic and finished film by
legendary director Orson Welles go
straight to streaming but here we are on
the cusp of the Netflix release of a
film over 40 years in the making
well supposedly left behind 10 hours of
war footage for his satirical
mockumentary and it's now been
painstakingly edited together into a
finished product the other side of the
wind' premieres on November 2nd
side-by-side with they'll love me when
I'm dead a documentary that explores the
making of the film in this one-man show
John Leguizamo delivers a comedy filled
stage drama that traces Latin history
from the Mayans to the modern day the
show garnered Leguizamo a Tony
nomination for Best Play and Netflix
brought their cameras to capture one of
the acclaimed performances in June 2018
tune into John Leguizamo's Latin history
for morons on November 5th Chris Pine
stars in his upcoming Netflix film has
Robert the Bruce the real-life
historical figure who organized the
Scottish clans to go to war against
England from the looks of the trailer so
far our Lord King will be a bloody romp
through history that tracks Roberts path
from fugitive to King of Scots take a
look on November 9
Halloween certainly doesn't mark the end
of the years horror releases as Netflix
is upcoming may the devil take you Bruce
the Indonesian fright flick focuses on a
younger woman who travels to her
father's old house after he falls into a
coma there she discovers that dear old
dad had more than a few skeletons in his
closet and some of them want to kill her
get ready for a dark descent into hell
when may the devil take you hits Netflix
on November 15th you probably won't
recognized Madeleine Brewers name but
her face may ring a bell the young
actress appeared in orange is the new
black the hamate stale and Black Mirror
and now she's set to star in Netflix's
newest psychological thriller camera the
film follows Alice a webcam girl whose
life is hijacked by someone who looks
just like her that kicks off a harrowing
mystery as Alice tries to figure out
what's her doppelganger wants from her
check it out on November 16th the narcho
spin-off narcos mexico puts a new cast
of characters at the start of the
Mexican drug war setting the series in
the early 80s and chronicling the bloody
beginnings of a violent cartel Michael
Pena and Diego Luna are set to star and
a new take on the series looks like
you'll be downright brutal but also
pretty amazing dig in on November 16th
there's been a lot of hype building for
The Ballad of Buster Scruggs the newest
release from Joel and Ethan Coen the
anthology film twins together six
different stories about the American
West
each infused with the kind of dark
comedy that could only come from the
Coen brothers Buster Scruggs has already
hit the 2018 festival circuit and
critics are loving it for the rest of
the world fall in love to find out when
it rides onto Netflix on November 16th
among golda historical shows on Netflix
the last Kingdom tends to fall between
the cracks that's a shame because this
period epic is definitely worth the time
to watch originally created by BBC the
last Kingdom follows a warrior in the
ninth century during a time when what is
now England was being overrun by the
invading Danes between its high
production values a solid storytelling
and breathtaking battles the last
Kingdom is definitely worth checking out
season 3 hits Netflix on November 19th
not to be confused to the other share
about the Archie comics character this
Sabrina is a horror film about a doll
that comes to life after a little girl
tries to bring her mother back from the
dead
a cheerful premise and the trailer for
Sabrina suggests that it only gets worse
from there look for it to hit Netflix on
November 20th the 2017 return of Mystery
Science Theater 3000 gave fans plenty to
love all the charm of the old series was
back along with a brand new set of
terrible films to make fun of what's not
to like with the next season Jonah and
his Robo friends will be riffing on six
new movies grab your popcorn and settled
in for the new season on November 22nd
between the last Kingdom and frontier
Netflix is bringing plenty of historical
action to the small screen in November
frontier is set in the Canadian frontier
and follows an outlaw who's dead set on
wreaking havoc on the region's fur trade
the outlaw is Declan harp played by
Jason Momoa whether you're a longtime
fan or just now getting into frontier
you can look forward to season 3 when it
arrives on November 23rd Netflix has two
new stand-up specials slated for
November and each one is well worth a
watch on the 20th watch out for Trevor
Noah son of Patricia which sees The
Daily Show host on stage for an evening
of hard-hitting jokes then November 27th
heralds the arrival of a double dose of
comedy when Jeff Ross and Dave Attell
both take the stage and take turns
roasting each other in a special chord
bumping mics with Jeff Ross and Dave
Attell that's all of the good Netflix
originals coming in November
now let's highlight a few of the best
films hitting the streaming service our
fond Soaker owns excellent children of
men is a highlight of November's action
additions arriving on the first the
dystopian drama follows a disillusioned
alcoholic who's roped into protecting
the last known pregnant woman on earth
cuarón used extensively on takes while
filming leading to some pretty
jaw-dropping action scenes after that
look for Pirates of the Caribbean at
World's End to sail on to streaming on
November 4th there's also a flood of
irreverent comedy splashing onto Netflix
on the first look for deuce Bigalow
European gigolo
National Lampoon's Animal House and
scary movie 2 & 3 it might not be a
highbrow selection but it's bound to be
hilarious I can't believe I just said
that on the thriller side Netflix is
doubling down on his post Halloween
chills on the first keep your eyes open
for Cloverfield from dusk till dawn
Bram Stoker's Dracula and transcendence
on
twelve Netflix is checking in green room
an intense little movie about a band
stuck in a gig full of murderous
neo-nazis Anton Yelchin stars with a
sinister performance by Patrick Stewart
as a villain
[Music]